make way for the new Bentley Continental
GTC v8 pure luxury and sweet on the year
too
this four-wheel dream packs 373
kilowatts of power with maximum torque
of 660 Newton meters and despite all the
superlatives this is the bottom of the
Continental range there's a 12 cylinder
as well the nice thing about any
convertible is that on a nice day like
today you can put the top down hit a
quiet country road let your mind run
free and let your hair blow wild in the
wind that's if you've got any hair but
back to the test we're looking at
performance here the GTC v8 has a top
speed of 303 kilometers an hour and that
comes at a price one hundred seventy
nine thousand eight hundred nine euros
for this model in Germany the large air
intake at the front means plenty of cool
air in the engine compartment the
daytime running lamps have 18 LEDs
integrated around them the black circle
is a distance sensor the roof closes in
30 seconds here we sped it up a little
with the roof closed the convertible
appears balanced the line traced by the
roof is in harmony with the limousine
aesthetic
it takes 25 seconds to pull back the
roof the mechanism runs smoothly here
it's in fast motion
the Bentley logo is on the trunk of the
car as well as at the front press the B
and the trunk opens automatically
whether the roof is open or closed the
volume doesn't change there's plenty of
space for luggage for a weekend trip
there's even a Bentley logo on the
headrests but the steering wheel is a
little strange
another little drawback might be these
gearshift levers on the steering column
you're a bit disturbing I first thought
I was using the blinker the pedals and
the rest of the interior are designed
with close attention to detail the
comfort in the front seat and this
Bentley is actually excellent but adult
passengers would have the right to
criticize the backseat accommodations
unless of course you're a miniscule
munchkin and what do you think yeah
speechless right
but one thing is clear after the
test-drive the driver's seat is the best
place to be the concentrated power of
the Bentley could make you forget the
luxury surroundings as with any Bentley
the interior combines high-tech
convenience with old-world charm the GT
sees cabin boasts some of the finest
materials you can find in an automobile
from supple leather to handcrafted rich
veneer it's one of those things you just
have to enjoy and touch